ich bin enttäuscht dass ich überhaupt
über dieses Thema sprechen muss und zwar
geht es mir hauptsächlich darum dass wir
uns jeden Tag über Kosten von
Energiestrom und Gas unterhalten und
vergessen dabei die wichtigste Energie
überhaupt die Landwirte hunderttausende
noch 200.000 knapp in Deutschland jeden
Tag für uns produzieren aus Sonne Erde
und ein unfassbaren Know-how und uns
jeden Tag versorgen und genau das steht
auf dem Spiel
Europa aber auch Deutschland forciert
immer mehr Abkommen mit Ländern wie
Südamerika das Merkur so Abkommen oder
ceta-abkommen was jetzt neulich erst
beschlossen wurde mit Kanada wir
importieren Ware die nicht ansatzweise
unsere Standards hat und wir reden den
ganzen Tag von Klimaschutz Artenschutz
wir reden von Kreislaufwirtschaft oder
das Gegenteil passiert jeden Tag sterben
in Deutschland 10 Höfe und die kommen
niemals wieder weil wenn diese
Energiequellen also die Nahrung die wir
zu uns nehmen nicht mehr zu uns
herkommen kann haben wir einen massives
Problem